Hi! I’m Alex, I’m a Software Engineer
here at Google and I work on Google Chrome
Frame -- a plug-in that’s bringing HTML5
and rich, modern web apps to IE 6, 7, and
8. We launched a developer preview of the
plug-in last Fall. Since then we’ve been
working hard to improve privacy, security,
and ease of deployment. We’ve also dramatically
improved the performance of the plug-in.
A stable version of Google Chrome Frame is
now available. Users of the beta will be automatically
updated to it and because Google Chrome Frame
is out of beta, you can now build rich apps
with HTML5’s audio, video, and canvas tags
without resorting to heavyweight shims and
frameworks that can slow down your site. New
features like CSS animations and SVG work
great in Google Chrome Frame, and I’m certain
that once you develop sites with modern web
technology, you’ll never want to go back.
So how do you make your site work with Google
Chrome Frame?
Once installed, Google Chrome Frame inspects
pages served to IE, looking for a special
HTTP header or META tag.
Adding the meta tag to your site is simple,
but remember that it should go at the very
top of your documents. If it’s too far down,
the plug-in might not see the tag.
The fastest and most reliable way to trigger
page rendering in Google Chrome Frame is by
using the HTTP header.
Adding the header site-wide is often a simple
matter of including the right directives in
a template or in your web server configuration.
Here we’ll add a header in an Apache configuration,
restart the server, and see that when we visit
the site again we can right-click to use Chrome’s
Web Inspector... which is how we know the
page is being rendered with Google Chrome
Frame.
Scripts like CFInstall and Modernizr can help
you prompt users without the plug-in to upgrade
or install Google Chrome Frame. Prompting
users is totally optional though, and users
who don’t have the plug-in just get IE’s
existing behavior. Check out the documentation
at code.google.com/chrome/chromeframe for
details, but don’t worry, we’ve worked
to keep that part simple too.
Thanks to HTML5, your rich apps can shine
without proprietary plug-ins and now, thanks
to Google Chrome Frame, you don’t even have
to leave users of legacy browsers behind.
Thanks for listening and for adding the headers
to your next HTML5-powered project.